in 1984 Spanish car maker Sega released
their first car as an independent
company theab itza while the automotive
industry boomed in much of post Second
World War Europe Spain lagged far behind
as our tester Christophe Bower explains
in the 1950s when Seiya was found in
Spain was really a developing country in
terms of its automotive industry the
streets worn for conditioned cars a
luxury restricted to the upper class and
buses the most common form of transport
but that soon changed in 1953 the first
C OTT left the production line at the
zona franca Factory in Barcelona C OTT
was still a state-owned company and
until the 1980s had produced only Fiat
models under license the very first see
out was the 1400 a midsize sedan
followed by the 1500 C I produced a
whole range of Fiat derivatives
including one of its most popular cars
the Seon 600 and the Panda in the 1980s
in 1984 the newly independent seeit
released the Ibiza with it's very own
stylings including a black radiator
grille and black bumpers christophe says
the prototype he beats it was called the
s-1 as in number one saya a name that
signifies a radical new beginning
independence from Fiat gave SIA a blank
slate in Barcelona the finished product
was then crowned the Ibiza after the
Balearic Islands which laid the
foundations for all future se out names
each further vehicle was named after a
Spanish city or region like Cordoba
Marbella and Alhambra hang on
is an alumna of Fort christophe as well
it still sounds good which probably
wouldn't be the case in Germany the
shrine for it whistles time with Castro
Walsall not quite so sexy
after its split from Fiat in 1981 see
outside the production agreement with
Volkswagen in 1986 SIA was incorporated
into the VW Group and after 10 years of
scrambling in the dirt these Spanish car
makers were back in the black christophe
explains that during the EBS
developments a at received massive
support from across Europe the design
came from Italy the bodywork concept
from German manufacturer Carmen and
osnabrück and the engine from Porsche in
Stuttgart Porsche also fine-tuned the
chassis making it Nitza
a real gem of its class with excellent
role holding and performance that it
couldn't be really proud of
Christoph's 1.2 liter model with 71
horsepower has a top speed of 158 km/h
the CIB beats awaz the most advanced
compact car of its time
they're CID bits Krista thinks the
sanity beats as an archetypal modern
compact car small but roomy it's exactly
the same length as the VW Polo of the
time with roughly the same wheelbase as
the Gulf mk2 and the result extremely
short overhangs at the front and back
providing extra space inside for
passengers and luggage
this angular hatchback was originally
available as a three-door model only but
the five-door followed in 1986 granted
some vintage car lovers would say it's
not much to look at but the first Ibiza
has gone on to become a vintage classic
and a testimony to the no frills 80s the
interior is just as roomy and
comfortable as higher classification
vehicles but the plastic fittings give
it a rather underclass feel by decency
at deep it's a Honda see this Ibiza was
released in 1991 christophe explains
after it it undergone a facelift the new
version at different bumpers white turn
indicators and this unusual plastic
covering for the radiator grille which
christophe didn't think much of time to
take a look under the hood this is a
four-cylinder engine from porsche at a
choice a reputation of being
maneuverable and sporty and efficient
and of course Porsches signature has
extra panache and extra cost to see out
though the license for each engine with
a Porsche logo ransie at 7 darks it's a
sound investment for the customer and
probably the cheapest way to drive a
Porsche of sorts
the 1.2 liter 71 horsepower engine gave
the car respectable performance for the
time at a meager 890 kilograms the first
CID beats a weighed as much as a modern
smart car and say it soon smoothed out
any teething problems it had with
quality control during early production
yes Christophe reckons the CID beats it
was a car ahead of its time built with
love and a joy to drive and increase its
export rate by 76% of course not many
cars had been sold abroad before that
but this success made it an attractive
brand and in 1986 Volkswagen took over
the company and so this say at Ibiza is
not just the first it's the only genuine
seeit because the second generation
starting in 1993 was based entirely on
the VW Polo and it was definitely
Volkswagens baby fun fun with over five
million vehicles produced the SE at
Ibiza has long been spain's best-selling
car even today this sporty dynamic
little car is a big hit with young
drivers